yeah well i don't want to be stuck in
that it's a fire tornado i mean what
that's full on you can rely on australia
to turn up the weather so weird that it
gets its own nickname fire nato a scary
vortex of flames spinning at 200
kilometers an hour i know it sounds like
a bad film but i promise you these
things are very real
at the far right the funnel of the
tornado comes into view
this is rather frightening
[Music]
[Music]
the first ever one of these that was
documented happened in australia's
capital in 2003.
i found a local who experienced it
firsthand
hi christine january 18 2003
can you talk me through that day okay
well it was hot it was blindingly hot
and our daughter knocked on the door and
said
have you guys got any idea what's going
on outside and we went
no and we went outside and there was
just these columns of smoke just
pouring out it was terrifying and next
thing
this noise it was like a jet liner was
about to land on our roof the house was
just vibrating residents didn't know it
but the fire had morphed into a tornado
the woman at the end of the street told
us this thing whatever it was had taken
her roof off the complete roof lifted it
up and deposited on mount taylor we saw
it there for weeks after could anything
have sort of prepared you for that
particular day
nothing
absolutely
absolutely nothing
i think you have to live through a
tornado to know what a tornado feels
like to know that
it was just like being in the middle of
hell
everything is suspended the laws of
nature are suspended nothing could have
prepared me for that
true fire tornadoes are rare most of the
videos you'll see online are actually
fire worlds the difference is in the way
they're formed firewells are spiraling
flames they whip up in a bushfire when
wind catches from both directions
firewalls tend to be smaller and usually
you'll have a spinning column of flame
um
quite visible but a fire tornado is
something more fierce it's literally a
tornado made of fire for this you need a
fire big enough to create its own
weather storm a fire tornado is really a
weather event inside a larger weather
event being that the firestorm you're
going to have bits of embers and
flames carried alongs it's basically all
the things that you get from a regular
tornado that's throwing in fire and
embers as well
only a unique set of conditions will
trigger a fire tornado you've got
the winds creating rotation
within the air in the air mass
once you get a
thunderstorm forming over that you get
big updrafts which then will sort of
tilt that rotating air upwards and if
you get enough rotation throughout that
whole column of air then that's when you
start to get a
a tornado wind and fire make a powerful
duo but let's take a closer look at the
physics
[Music]
obviously we can't build a thunderstorm
in here instead we're going to make a
firework so we can see how the wind
influences the vortex at the base of a
tea like candle add some rubbing alcohol
goggles gloves light it up
now let's see what happens when we put
the cylinder on top
[Music]
nothing
but
if we offset the cylinder a little bit
whoa
we have a firewall that's a pretty cool
trick
that's spinning convection at play to
get the flame to spin we need to
introduce some form of rotation so when
i offset the cylinder it forces the air
to move in opposite directions that
starts the spinning rotation and then
the upwards heat causes the flame to go
zhang
firewells are a lot more common than
their super-sized tornado cousins but
could we be seeing more fire tornadoes
in the future
i mean it really comes down to how prone
you are of getting these large
firestorms developing if you get one of
those intense enough
forming then there's always going to be
a likelihood that a tornado could form
the 2019 black summer saw over 30
firestorms a record number so what we
see when we look at
um climate change trends are they those
dangerous conditions are occurring more
often particularly in southern australia
here hot dry landscapes and cold air
fronts form a lethal combo to make a
thunderstorm thunderstorms actually like
a bit of moisture that involves these
these cold fronts which periodically
come across the bottom of australia and
when the front comes in you've got that
that instability in the atmosphere so
firestorms will become more prevalent so
firestorms are on the rise does that
possibly mean more fire nato's we
haven't yet been able to
understand how that might relate to a
fire generated tornado i think that's
going to be
a few more years or more of research
needed until we get to that point
[Music]
you